ارتداء حزام الامان اثناء القياده اجباري
ومن الضروري ان يربط كافه الركاب حزام
الامان في السياره مخالفه ذلك تفرض على
صاحبها غرامه قد تصل الى 500 جنيه
بعد ظهور رئيس الوزراء ريشه سوناك في
فيديو لا يرتدي فيه حزام الامان فيما
سيارته تتحرك سوناك اعتذر عن خلع حزام
الامان خلال التصويره المقطع لمتابعه على
الانستغرام واعتبره خطا في التقدير سونار
قد يتلقى غرامه ماليه على هذه المخالفه
الجديده بعد تغريمه 50 جنيه العام الماضي
لخلقه قواعد كورونا عندما كان وزير
الماليه في عهد حكومه باريس جونسون
لا تشرع قانون
يوسف السكن
الثانيه غرامه الله بعد مخالفته القانون
مرتين في الحكومه البريطانيه الا اذا وجدت
الشرطه التبريرا المقنعا لعدم ارتداء حزام
الامان وذلك في الحالات الاستثنائيه
الصحيه المحدوده وهذا مستبعد في حاله
سوناك لا احد يستخفه بالتحديات التي
تواجهه بريطانيا من اقتصاد المتعثر وغلاء
المعيشه واضرابات تتسع عدتها والان ريشه
هناك الذي يقود البلاد في هذه المرحله
الحرجه في ازمه خاصه بسبب خلقه القانونه
خلال اداء مهامه وان لم تكن تابعتها واضحه
بعد
مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن